[Music]
go to kuala lude app inshallah the app
tracks versus pages and time spent
reading and the verses to pages function
takes you from reading a few verses a
day to a few pages a day this project is
for the real enthusiasts if there's
enough of us out there this will become
the future of quran
and support the project if you can insha
allah may allah bless all of you
assalamu
how are you guys doing and welcome to
the third
of a series of videos we're doing
correcting some of the mistakes of dr
jordan peterson about islam and muslims
and really this series is uh intended to
edify and to educate not just jordan
peterson himself but some of his
followers who maybe may have
been misled with all due respect on
certain points of information that dr
jordan peterson an influential figure as
he is
has made about islam and muslims today
in sha allah we're going to be covering
two or three different statements that
he has made let's start with the first
one because it's um a historical and
it's easy to refute let's take a look at
it when the founder of your religion
spread that religion by the sword
it makes it rather difficult and when
your religion has been embroiled in a
vicious civil war from the day of
muhammad's death which is exactly the
case in islam between the sunnis and the
shiites that war started literally the
day that muhammad died it's very
difficult for me to see how that can be
reconciled with the claims that islam is
a religion of peace right so he states
that
islam was embroiled in a vicious civil
war
our question is can you name me with i
know you're watching this dr jordan
peterson because
uh clearly it would make sense for you
to do so
what is the name of that civil war
you're talking about that commenced the
day the prophet salallahu
and please give me a source for that
because
let me tell you something dr jordan
pearson no such war took place
now you may say well the war took place
30 years after safiy and jamal these
wars took place 30 to 40 years after but
that's not
what you said
you stated that it happened the day
the prophet died and then you use that
as a point
um just to to conclude
that you can't
reconcile this fact with the fact that
islam is a religion of peace
so already you've got a point that you
want to make and the evidence that
you're using doesn't match this point
and in fact it's a false piece of
evidence and it's another example where
you violate your own rules
the rules um namely the rules to speak
the truth or at least don't lie
and be precise in speech you violate
your own rules you're not precise here
this is inaccurate for an intellectual
you need to be more careful with all due
respect because if you don't know
something and this is false according to
all accounts there was no war sorry
dr peterson there was no war that
commenced the day the prophet died this
is false
but as an intellectual or as an academic
you should check before you speak with
all due respect
and already this you could say i mean
you have to ask yourself dr jordan
peterson are you making this point to
try and score points against islam
because you already have a cognitive
bias
because the pulse
the evidence you used was a false piece
of evidence so what is the motivating
factor here
now the point that you were making about
islam being a religion of peace
look i'm not in favor of calling islam a
religion of peace
but i'm not in favor of calling islam a
religion of war either because islam
really means it's islam which means
submission
and islam
is submission to one god
submission and worship of the god of
abraham the god of moses and the god of
jesus the god of muhammad
this is what primarily islam is
which leads me on to your second point
because you state islam is primarily a
political system let's take a look at
what you have to say but i'm really
stumbling with islam it's really hard
for me to
to see it as
other than a primarily political system
this is false dr peterson with all due
respect
i don't know of any scholar of islam
in the classical period who defined
islam vastly that islam is a political
system primarily a political system how
could it be
it's a very there's a very clear
theocentric motif in the quran
a book of
6236 verses which has been translated
the meanings of have been translated
into english
and i don't think that statement that
you've mentioned about islam is anywhere
to be found in the quran
and it's nowhere to be found in the
statements of the prophet
so where do you get this idea that islam
is primarily a political system
why is this the narrative that you want
to portray
what is the motivating factor here this
is false as i've mentioned islam quite
clearly
at the center center of islam or central
to it is the idea of monotheism
monotheism to worship one god that's
really the the main message of islam the
shahada is
there is no god worthy of worship
except for allah the creator of the
heavens and the earth the higher power
the higher power which jesus himself
beseeched and prayed to that moses
prayed to that abraham prayed to
we don't believe that jesus was god or
the son of god we don't believe that a
man can be god we don't believe in any
of those things the center of our faith
is very simply to worship one god that
is islam
so to to call it primarily a political
system
is
false it's imprecise speech
or it's not speaking the truth of islam
what islam is
then you go on to say something which is
i believe is a slight and i believe it's
an attempt to try and score points
against islam it's very clear that it is
but it's also
weak as an argument let's see what you
have to say about islam
or muslim countries and
the state of economic affairs in muslim
countries you know the
the
states dominated by islam are not
economically productive
and that's quite an interesting mystery
so this point that jordan peterson makes
here he says states that are occupied by
islam are not economically productive
first of all how do you define occupied
by islam and secondly how do you define
economically productive
what are the
measures that you're using gdp per
capita for example where four muslim
majority countries are in the top ten
which ones are you talking about are you
talking about gdp
or what exactly and i must say this is a
methodologically flawed approach in the
first instance
analyzing an ideology
and
economic productivity of a country why
because why today first of all first of
all why today why not look 400 years ago
in the ottoman empire or islamic spain
or the abbasids or the omo yon or the
khilaf rashidah when economic
productivity was very high and islam was
being implemented at a much more strict
level if you like
is it because it fits a particular
narrative which may indicate that
islam as a religion inhibits economic
productivity
similar to the kind of narrative we
dealt with in the previous episode
this is a weak argument i'm really sorry
it's a weak argument and with all due
respect you weren't even brave enough to
make the argument properly because you
said it's an interesting mystery and you
shroud
your sentences
with words of ambiguity and uncertainty
when
with all due respect sometimes you don't
want to make the argument directly
because you know it's susceptible to a
high level refutation like the one
you're seeing right now
because the question is if it's to do
with ideology
my question to you is in the mid 18th
century 1760 when the industrial
revolution started in britain for
example
what were what was the state of affairs
relating to ideologies the same are the
morals and ethics
of britain in the 18th century
similar or distinctly different from the
moles and ethics that we're seeing today
in the 21st century i would wager
especially on women's rights that's
completely different
and in fact that was a time
where economic productivity in britain
was very very high comparative to the
other states in fact you could say the
highest
you can make this argument
and so if it was to do with ideology
then once again you'd expect
the morals and the ethics
and the ideological standpoints to have
an impact in the inhibitive or negative
effect of that economy
likewise you can say the same thing
about the slave trade
well
america was doing very well when it had
black slaves
it was doing very well when it was
trading them and when it was forcing
them to pick cotton and so on
before the um american civil war
in the mid 19th century
were the morals and the ethics and the
ideological standpoints especially of
let's say southern states in america
were they the same or distinctly
different from the way they are now
i think you would say the latter
so much so that i had a constitutional
effect with the third the 13th amendment
and other such things that happened in
the cultural atmosphere in america
ideological differences
yet despite the ideological differences
which
one can notice
in the mid-19th century say and now say
in american culture
we still see that america was doing very
well economically at a time where its
ideology was different to the way it is
now
so if ideology
or liberal or the liberal ideology of
today let's say western ideology of
today
the cultural and
uh
moral and ethical standpoints of the
west today
were
shaping forces for how the economy
behaves
then why do we see that it behaves
in sometimes even a comparatively
stronger way
in the past where ethics were different
in america and in the west generally
to the way it is now so you see this is
a methodologically flawed thing because
we're seeing transient ethics here and
this is really
basic for a social scientist that
correlation does not always mean
causation
and if it was to do with ethics and
morals and ideology then why do we
seeing the rise of japan
japan is not a western country and it
has ethics and cultures distinct from
the west and yet we're seeing its
economy rise as staggering rate
technological and scientific and
economic developments there
moreover if you wanted to play this game
we can go further
and we can say to you
that in fact
most i'm not going to say most but many
of the countries which are
which have let's say western enlightened
enlightenment ideas in sub-saharan
africa
and in southern
uh in in southern america
are below the poverty line and in fact
do worse than even on a gdp level okay
muslim majority countries so if what we
are saying is if we put western
enlightenment ideas
into countries we expect the economic
development to be
better then why are we not seeing that
in countries
in south america and sub-saharan africa
where they're
indebted where they're impoverished
and so on
so you see it's a failed attempt a
slight at the islamic civilization and a
weak argument that we expected better
from dr jordan peterson and it's these
kinds of arguments with all due respect
which go back to our theme
the theme is you're trying to whitewash
the muslim contribution you're trying to
minimize the islamic contribution and
somehow and you could say with this with
this kind of lexus here it's clear that
you're trying to connect
failure
with islam somehow whether it's economic
failure scientific failure or
lack of productivity or whatever it may
be with islam
and it's failed the arguments have
failed and maybe this is the reason why
you didn't want to have a discussion
with me because you knew these things
are on the record and you knew you'd be
accounted for it but i think it's high
time jordan peterson if we want to have
an authentic discussion we have to start
with retractions because these kinds of
things are not just imprecise as we've
shown sorry they're imprecise they're a
historical they're inaccurate but
they're weak as arguments and unless one
revises and retracts or otherwise
suspends at least suspends judgments
on issues to do like with these kinds of
points that you've mentioned here
then how are we going to have a proper
dialogue
between islam about islam and the west
for example in the interaction between
these two things if we can separate them
at all and hopefully
that edified some of jordan peterson's
followers
and insha'allah even jordan peterson
himself